10h25 on parle livres pour enfants
puisque régulièrement nous partageons
des conseils lecture avec vous typhaine
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse aux enfants
qui n'ont pas vraiment été sage et wiba
la plupart des enfants ne sont pas très
sale et les chiens font pas de louer
mais voilà je fais pression des messages
ouais bon ballon pêche restent alors les
enfants souvent sont très malicieux
surtout quand ils font des bêtises
alors pour ces enfants là j'ai ce livre
là et la suite le monstre dans le lac du
placard existe et je vais vous le
prouver et comment élever le monstre du
placard dont paul ohl et bruno salomone
à actes sud junior alors je vous
explique c'est un enfant qui se retrouve
avec un monstre dans son placard et
alors ce monstre là évidemment n'est pas
très sage il laisse traîner ses jouets
il laisse des miettes du gâteau souli
des signes sur les murs bon évidemment
c'est un monstre qui est très pratique
un moment où les parents débarquent dans
la chambre s'apprête à disputer
l'enfance et le monstre que tous les
parents connaissent un petit peu tout
voyez ce que je veux dire le monstre
bien utile le monstre alibi mais bon
c'est un livre très drôle qui plaît
beaucoup aux enfants
et puis voilà en fait on se clôt par
hausse est notable
vous voyez les dessins sont vraiment
sympas et et puis ça permet de parler
aussi des petites bêtises et puis des
petits mensonges du quotidien et dans la
famille des enfants turbulents vous avez
choisi au sud de pôle de solides dont
j'adore le titre la tribu qui pue délice
gravel et magali le huche aux éditions
les fourmis rouges alors c'est très
simple c'est une tribu d'enfants
sauvages
voilà qui vivent en autonomie qui
cueille qui pêche qui recycle tout ce
qu'elles trouvent mais mon problème
c'est que c'est une tribu ben du coup
très indépendante et les adultes du
village d'à côté voudrait bien les
dompter un petit peu les envoyer à
l'orphelinat et surtout les laver et ça
va pas être si simple
et en fait 20 c les enfants qui vont
finalement dompter les adultes alors
c'est un livre à ces insolents qui en
fait est un pied-de-nez à la discipline
qui est aussi assez écolo et qui plaît
beaucoup aux enfants à partir du cp donc
voilà je vous le conseille la tribu qui
pêchent une petite parenthèse florence
je me sentais très attentifs parce qu on
se pose tous la question comment on se
lave en laponie quand on est parti comme
ça pendant six semaines n'a pas trop le
temps mais ça fait de deux livres non
l'aventurière quiétude non ça n'existe
pas un homme peut-être pas parvenu en
tout cas bon départ mais c'est vrai que
c'est un sens là sont plutôt aventuriers
quand même voilà ils cueillent devais me
débrouille quand même aller un autre
livre le dernier
alors imaginez que marie desplechin
rencontre claude ponti alors à eux deux
ils ont écrit des dizaines de livres
pour enfants et cette fois ci il décide
de raconter l'enfance des personnages
célèbres
alors ça va de jésus-christ à
hatshepsout à charlie chaplin
alors c'est romancé c'est très mignon
vous voyez que le petit bard essaye de
montrer l'enfant qui est caché derrière
les représentations les plus célèbres
voilà qui ont marqué un peu les esprits
vraiment je vous conseille ce livre
c'est un très beau livre c'est à la fois
un livre pour enfants et pour adultes
c'est inspirera peut-être les enfants
voilà ça plaira aux adultes
et puis voilà il faut faut se dire que
tous les enfants sont malicieux et que
ça donne parfois d'un dd jolie carrière
des baux destin c'est un très beau livre
non j'aime bien en tout cas les
construit de lecture pour les jeunes et
puis pour les parents ou les
grands-parents que nous sommes aussi
c'est important à retrouver évidemment
sur le replay de france 3 merci tiphaine
pour ses jolies conseil lek